Perfetto Ok Innanzitutto grazie mille
per avermi ospitato a questo evento come
potete vedere il titolo è empowerment
quando la testa governa sul corpo e se
non fosse così allora io questa sera non
dovrei essere qui di fronte a voi Quindi
per me questa è proprio proprio una
legge di vita ed è quello che accade in
fin dei primi anni fin dai primi anni e
che cosa succede per me la vertigine è
qualcosa di ricorrente nella mia vita
così ricorrente che ho instaurato un
rapporto questo rapporto è di profonda
stima e affetto nei suoi confronti
perché perché ogni volta che si è
presentata a me questo senso di
vertigine io l'ho affrontata potevo
schivarle invece ho deciso di
affrontarla e affrontandola ho capito
che potevo sempre fare quel +1 potevo
salire Quel gradino ogni volta per me
era un'evoluzione un passo in più per
poter per poter crescere
ed effettivamente è stato è stato
ipotesi E rappresenta un'evoluzione
pensate che la mia vita è caratterizzata
in periodi più o meno lunghi da questo
senso di vertigine e tra le diverse
evoluzioni che ho potuto affrontare nel
mio percorso sicuramente la più grande è
quella a cui sono affeziona più
affezionato e quella di aver trasformato
quello che per tutti era il mio punto
debole In realtà nella nella mia arma
vincente che non è altro che la mia
altezza e perché vi dico questo perché
fin da fin da piccolino per amici e
parenti la mia altezza sembrava
fondamentalmente il peggiore dei mali da
chi si interroga Ma come mai vostro
figlio è così alto basta guardare i miei
genitori non è che son giganti oppure
non potrai avere successo nella tua vita
perché sei piccolino perché nello sport
ci vuol il fisico e nel lavoro ci
vogliono i requisiti di altezza
Se questo è quello che pensate voi
Vediamo se da adesso in poi
rispecchiarà quello che il vostro volere
o il mio volere perché
deve essere chiaro una cosa quando si
parla con una persona non si sa mai la
storia che c'è dietro ad ognuno di noi
Soprattutto parlando con dei ragazzini
a volte avendo poca sensibilità forse
anche con un velo di ignoranza non si
può sapere che reazione verrà scaturita
all'interno di quel ragazzino in genere
può essere o mortificazione o sfida per
me personalmente ragazzi è sempre stato
una sfida perché penso che con la
vertigine ci
sia un forte senso mi porta adrenalina e
io vivo per l'adrenalina ok Quindi ogni
volta che sembra che sto per cadere o
una voglia di far qualcosa devo farla
devo farla perché mi fa sentire vivo
quel brivido Quella quella sensazione
forte dirmi ok ci sono ok Ho deciso io
perché è chiaro che non possiamo vivere
una vita che qualcuno progetta per noi
chi sono gli altri per poter pensare Chi
siamo noi E chi Dobbiamo essere noi
invece io ho sempre semplicemente scelto
di vivere come volevo io e quindi
affrontando questo senso di vertigine e
24h questo Ragazzi è chiaro che il
Grazie più grande va ai miei genitori
perché perché partendo da mia mamma e ho
sempre imparato a sorridere nella mia
vita e perché perché detto da una donna
che si sveglia alle 3:30 4:00 del
mattino per andare a lavorare nei campi
e poi mantieni in maniera impeccabile
una famiglia e sorridendo e ti dice
guarda che se hai uno scopo nella vita
non è vero che devi fare dei sacrifici
perché la parola sacrificio è una parola
negativa vuol dire escludere qualcosa
per farle entrare un'altra quando invece
nella vita se hai bisogno se ti fa
sentire bene qualcosa il tuo tempo le
tue forze vanno investite non vanno
sacrificate per non parlare poi di mio
padre che fin da piccolino mi portava a
spasso in macchina e mi raccontava tutte
le sue storie di vita e mi diceva quali
avvenimento quali situazioni avrei
potuto incontrare dalle ragazzine al
lavoro e vi sembrerà pazzesco fare
parole non profetiche perché ancora ad
oggi nella mia vita nel mio lavoro
ritrovo tanto di quello di quello che mi
ha mi raccontava lui e quindi questa è
la vita che ho scelto ho scelto di
sentire sulla mia pelle questo senso di
vertigine e andarli incontro pensate che
tutto questo inizia da quando avevo 6
anni era così piccolino sì da così
piccolino Perché quando ero piccolino io
Tutti volevano giocare a calcio pure io
quindi la prima cosa che facevano i
genitori ti scrivevano a scuola calcio
Vai vai Allora ragazzi io mi sentivo
parte di un gruppo perché eravamo tutti
amici mi divertivo ma non lo sentivo mio
sì tantissimi divertivo giocavo che
ragazzi non lo sentivo davvero mio
Quindi da lì a poco abbandonare dopo un
annetto un annetto e mezzo passo passo
non molto tempo Io in genere andavo a
letto alle 9:00 e mezza di sera ero
ragazzino quando invece una sera a mio
padre si avvicina e fa guardarò stasera
passano in televisione un film di Bruce
Lee sai e mi racconto di quando dovevo
andare al cinema per vedere i film di
questo Bruce Lee quindi la sera che cosa
succede che io adesso con lui sul divano
a vedere questo film non l'avesse mai
fatto perché poi dal giorno dopo ho
iniziato Papà voglio andare a fare
karate Papà voglio andare a far karate
mio padre e dicevo ma come mai volevi
vedere il calcio calcio calcio l'hai
lasciato Mo ti sei visto un film vuoi
andare a far karate io gli spiegai che
non era tanto il voler imparare a fare a
botte perché poi la loro preoccupazione
che io diventasse Aggressivo ma era il
messaggio che mi aveva lasciato Sì è
vero ero un ragazzino ma vedere questo
questo signore questo ragazzo che è
scalato l'ultimo combattimento di Genova
che scalava questi livelli e più livelli
scalati più erano difficili le sfide e
lui le vinceva mi aveva affascinato dal
giorno io avevo circa nove anni dal
giorno qualche giorno dopo i miei
genitori si convinsero a portarmi in
palestra e da lì
Chi prima dubitava della mia altezza
inizio a dubitare Ma come Ma il karate
ma che Che sport è ma non è neanche uno
sport Mentre gli altri continuano a
dubitare che però stanno iniziando a
spiccare il volo Ed è proprio così
perché dovete capire che per quanto mi
riguarda è sempre stata una questione di
prospettiva Questa è un'immagine della
finale del gruppo della finale dei
Mondiali Vedendo questa foto le prime
cose che penso che ammazzo e quel
piccolino che ci fa là in mezzo no eh
Che cosa ci fai ci fa quello che era il
suo sogno Perché Perché iniziai a far
karate
arrivai poi all'età di 15 anni io ho
avuto la fortuna di studiare qui al
liceo scientifico di Policoro e non
potevo più continuare a far calare a
livello amatoriale vicino casa Avevo
bisogno di trovare qualcosa qui vicino
al liceo Perché nel pomeriggio potevo
andare ad allenarmi conobbi questo
maestro questo maestro era era
all'interno del mondo delle gare nel
mondo dell'agonismo dopo il primo
allenamento mi ricordo e mi disse
ragazzo io ti posso portare a gareggiare
Ma tu che obiettivo c'hai io l'ho
guardato di getto detto maestro
diventare campione del mondo ma tutta
una pacca sulla spalla mi fai il ragazzo
sogna è bello sognare ma non sempre i
sogni si realizzano Siccome nella mia
vita una cosa che mi ha sempre
contraddistinto è più mi mettono
pressione più dubitano di me e io più mi
esalto firmano una condanna la condanna
è che porterà a sbagliare loro e magari
porterà a fare qualcosa di buono dentro
di me così iniziai a gareggiare
Sicuramente non è stato semplice perché
venendo al liceo studiando matematica
fisica dovevo portare dei buoni voti
sono i miei genitori che li sentiva No
no se non hai portato l'insufficienza tu
non ti alleni più Eh no io dovevo
allenarmi Perché io avevo bisogno di
sentirmi vivo sicuramente ha iniziato il
periodo più bello della mia vita fra
studio e
gare e all'inizio non fu semplice perché
comunque entrano in un in un circuito
dove non ero conosciuto Quindi avevo
bisogno di lavorare lavoravamo tante ore
al giorno Poi io mi allenavo a Ginosa i
miei genitori nonostante si svegliassero
alle 4:00 la mattina o pomeriggio poi
dovevano viaggiare pure per portarmi lì
e una volta il maestro Mi guardò e mi
disse guardarocco sicuramente al momento
ancora non stanno riconoscendo quelle
che sono le tue doti ma ti racconti di
una cosa che ti deve servire anche nella
vita chiudi gli occhi alla fine della
tua prova alla fine del tuo collo di
quello che sarà un colloquio di lavoro
alla fine di un interrogazione a scuola
chiudi gli occhi pensi di aver fatto
tutto quello che dovevi fare Se la
risposta è sì apri gli occhi la gara
L'hai vinta il colloquio l'hai passato
l'interrogazione è andata bene e fu così
perché poi nel 2007 arriva la più grande
soddisfazione perché nella stagione
2006-2007 in un solo colpo vince titolo
italiano europei e titolo mondiale
quindi raggiunsi l'apice a circa l'età
di 18 anni
Grazie mille e finito il liceo Però
avevo la l'aspirazione è di crescere
Volevo spiccare ancora di più il volo e
allora Scelsi di andare a Milano cesti
andare a Milano e mi scrissi a Economia
e Finanza
ero bravo in matematica ma per fare
economia raga bisogna studiare Io
all'epoca gareggiavo viaggiavo facevo
stage e non mi potevo permettere questo
ma comunque portavo avanti Entrambe le
cose andava bene io li ho conosciuto un
altro Maestro questo maestro mi diede un
grande insegnamento una volta mi chiese
di ripetere Non so quante volte una
tecnica Io pensavo di averla fatta
perfetta quando invece non avevo
staccato neanche i piedi da terra e non
riuscivo ad alzarmi mi tremavano le
gambe lui si avvicina
mi guarda mi hai fatto Sei un campione
e si è visto quello che ho vinto No no
vattene a casa sei scarso perché un
campione sicuramente non poggia le
ginocchia per terra e resta lì raga
quella è stata una un insegnamento che
ancora oggi mi porto nella vita fidatevi
tante altre volte sono caduto e non solo
fisicamente anche moralmente ma non so
mai più rimasto con le ginocchia per
terra Mi sono sempre rialzato e sembrava
quasi volesse anticipare qualcosa perché
nel 2010 e nel 2012 per alcuni errori
arbitrali mi ha portato via un
campionato d'Europa e un campionato del
mondo ma la voglia di vincere di farmi
valere era era più forte quindi tornai
ad allenarmi più forte di prima dovevo
ero favorito per il campionato per il
campionato d'Europa non fece una brutta
scelta farmi una partita a calcetto con
gli amici e tu Voi direte roba perché è
stata una brutta scelta è stata
divertire no raga perché per colpa di un
infortunio ho rotto tutti i legamenti
del ginocchio siamo presi tutti i Meschi
e quindi la prima cosa che mi dissero E
tu sicuramente non puoi più saltare non
puoi più fare nulla che sia di esplosivo
tecnica esplosiva è stato sicuramente il
periodo più brutto della mia vita perché
non ho detto niente ai miei genitori non
ho detto niente ai miei amici ma avevo
perso tutte le certezze mi sentivo
vulnerabile perché non potevo più fare
quello per cui ero cresciuto e per
quello che avevo sempre vissuto fino a
quel momento lì quindi Scelsi di tornare
a Bari di tornare al sud mi mi trasferì
all'Università di Bari per fare economia
mentre i miei genitori pensavano che io
facevo economia a Bari in realtà mi
mettevo da parte i soldi andavo ogni due
mesi a Milano perché andavo a provare i
test in scienze motorie perché perché se
c'è una cosa che ho capito E che quando
una persona tocca il fondo fino a
grattarlo
dopo vuole risalire su e più sale e più
vuole salire se mentre gli altri pensano
che la soddisfazione è legata solo al
momento per me non è legata solo al
momento per me è legato al fatto che
ogni volta che guardo giù vedo quel
fondo che è sempre più lontano e quindi
ho capito che se fino a quel momento ero
stato un atleta forse non lo potevo più
essere anche se comunque sarei tornato
in gara perché era il ginocchio che
doveva dirmi di non gareggiare più e non
la mia mente ho capito che ok io quello
che ho imparato fino adesso posso
trasmetterlo sì che posso Allora Appunto
ho iniziato a fare questo bel pianeta a
Milano e passai i test in scienze
motorie entra in scienze motorie da lì a
poco entra in una grossa multinazionale
a lavorare nell'ambito del Fitness
tornai a gareggiare tornei a gareggiare
dopo neanche 4 mesi dall'intervento è
preso un bel bronzo ai campionati
d'Europa lì avevo dato la dimostrazione
che avevo ragione io che si poteva
tornare che si poteva anche cambiare ed
evolversi sta mandando tutto bene
aspettavo da lì a poco il mercato
effettivo in questa multinazionale in
più dovevo partecipare ai campionati del
mondo raga che cosa succede rompo la
seconda volta il ginocchio chiaramente
per farle bene le cose la prima volta ho
rotto il destro la seconda volta ho
rotto il sinistro e ho fatto più danni
allora la mia paura era quella che poi
non mi rinnovassero il contratto al
lavoro allora misi un tutore In modo
tale da non poter piegare il ginocchio
tutti i giorni mettendo il ghiaccio ogni
mezz'ora andavo al lavoro perché vivevo
per quelli io quello volevo fare Ma
perché me lo dovevano togliere ma tanto
la prima volta non me l'avevano tolta e
neanche questa volta sarebbe stato così
ed effettivamente Raga non è non è stato
così perché ho subito l'intervento sono
tornato al lavoro e da lì in poi sono
stato poi un fiume in piena e ogni volta
che guardo questa questa immagine mi
ricordo di dover Cacciare fuori sempre
tutto quello che ho dentro perché lì che
veramente poi puoi farla la differenza
quindi che cosa è successo o ho
proseguito nella mia carriera mi sono
tolto diverse soddisfazioni sono
basata sulla copertina di un importante
rivista A livello mondiale Oggi sono
Ambassador di un grande Brand sono
sponsorizzato da un grande Brand che mi
ha riconosciuto la mia storia di vita la
mia carriera sportiva e la mia carriera
lavorativa e stava andando tutto bene Ma
come vi ho detto a me piace sfidare la
vertigine quindi che cosa ho fatto non
poteva essere comunque un infortunio a
far finire la mia carriera sportiva è
vero il lavoro stava andando bene ma la
carriera sportiva era lì fermo perché mi
stavo dedicando al lavoro allora l'anno
scorso nel periodo di aprile che cosa ho
fatto sono tornato ad allenarmi mi sono
allenato per tre mesi a settembre sono
andato a partecipare ai campionati del
mondo e ancora questa volta sono
arrivato primo
perché perché
voglio voglio voglio voglio lasciarvi Io
poi devo ringraziare delle persone che
sono anche qui presenti quando ero
piccolino sono le prime che hanno
creduto in me mi hanno mi hanno
sponsorizzato mi davano soldini per
poter far sì che il mio sogno potesse
andare avanti e grazie mille di questo
vi lascio Vi lascio con questa
considerazione
Io ho fatto quello che pensavo fosse
giusto per la mia vita e mi facesse
sentire bene Ricordatevi non sempre
tutti i percorsi sono facili non sempre
è semplice ma non dimenticate mai quello
che avete quello che avete costruito
quando vi troverete in momenti difficili
chiudete gli occhi tornate indietro a
quando eravate piccolini vedrete un
ragazzino lì speranzoso in silenzio
mettetegli una mano sulla spalla e
ditegli tranquillo perché tutto quello
che hai pensato di fare nella tua vita
Guardami lo hai fatto quindi non ti
abbattere perché
perché solo riconoscendo il vostro
percorso è quello che avete costruito
sarete veramente grati a voi stessi
Grazie mille
[Applauso]